J'ai écrit cette chanson
avec mes amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des situations profondément personnelles
tiens-moi la main,
tout ira bien
J'ai entendu du ciel Que les nuages
ont été formidables,
rapproche-moi
Enveloppe-moi de tes douleurs,
je vois que tu  Je souffre de
ce que tu mets si longtemps
à me dire que tu as besoin de moi, je dis que tu
saignes, tu n'as pas besoin de me le montrer à nouveau,
mais si tu décides de le faire, je monterai dans cet
amour avec toi, je ne lâcherai pas prise.  jusqu'à la
fin
alors pleure
pleure ce soir
mais ne lâche pas mes mains
tu ne peux pas pleurer toutes les années je ne
partirai pas tant que je n'aurai pas
compris
promets-moi de juste tenir ma main
tenir ma main tenir ma
main  J'aurai raison
[Musique]
Je serai là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci